[Music]
welcome to the show
[Music]
came a long wait for the basement now
I'm a father like Kevin and Jason life
is amazing when it comes to your family
everything really come down to
communication all in your head about it
but don't forget about it just let it
out let's talk it out let's talk it out
let's talk it out let's talk it out
sit down
sit your ass down
hey boy you better are y'all tuning in
right now yeah Happy Father's Day from
Jay and Silent Bob I'm Kevin Smith Jason
Muse uh okay uh this kids is our second
attempt at a podcast our first attempt
was very successful it was James but
thank you for co-signing that it was
sounds so weakness
I should say this yeah it was Master I
didn't want to cut you off so I was like
should I talk no okay he does your
[ __ ] show we're here because of you
I'll explain to The Listener
um we did uh and have been doing and
we'll continue to do Jay and Silent Bob
get old
um for 12 years now uh now we
predominantly do it at Comic Cons and
whatnot
um but the premise of that show was an
intervention podcast that was meant to
keep Jason clean
12 years in uh you know everyone always
has to watch themselves but like Jason's
on a pretty strong path we don't need
the podcast to
constantly check in on his his uh old
drug behavior and to be honest like he
really ran out of [ __ ] to say about the
bad old days 100 yeah and towards the
end I I really I remember being like
wait a second it's all done I told that
story yeah it was kind of getting into
reruns even with the sex stories too
which I never thought was possible I
thought we'd run for 30 years these
[ __ ] [ __ ] so much but we
eventually hit a wall there too or it
was like yeah one day he was just like I
was like what what's your sex story he
goes
uh man like Jordan just had sex I was
like that's the sex story and he was
like I don't have anything I've told
every [ __ ] story I could tell so
music the other day was like out of the
blue uh you gotta realize I live right
around the block from Jason uh uh he he
well I guess you'll find out on this
podcast that's changing
um he's always lived like right nearby
even when we live together or not live
together live near each other in New
Jersey and Highlands the town we grew up
in Highlands New Jersey
he was always like a few blocks away uh
and then when him and his wife Jordan
bought a house uh they bought a house
like in the same neighborhood as I am I
could walk to Jay's house not break a
sweat if I have to and stuff so uh but
that being said I interact with uh
Jason's wife Jordan more than anything
else Jordan runs our company so I I'll
talk to Jordan like [ __ ] five six
times a day I'll see Jason if we're not
working
maybe once a week maybe twice a week or
something because Jason you know and
people are like what Jay and Silent Bob
are always together I just saw that they
went to Ben Affleck's wedding together
and stuff
um yes we we do see each other
frequently and whatnot but the person
that's Jason spends the most amount of
time with
is his daughter Logan
um that's the the hidden secret of muse
that you know I've been telling it for a
while when we were on the Jay and Silent
Bob reboot Road Show tour
I got to talk about it every night
because it influenced the movie Jane
Silent Bob reboot pushed in the
direction that we went with Jay the J
character being a father uh the real J
Jason Muse is hands down
the best dad I have ever encountered in
my life I include in that list my dad me
as a dad and if you believe in this [ __ ]
the Lord Our God as a dad because
technically you know when you step back
from it
he could have been nicer to his son oh
yeah you know like I I got a daughter I
would not let her be crucified no not
being judgy just saying
even for the the reasons that you know
he was yeah purportedly doing it yeah
even if my kid was like Dad I gotta do
this to save the world I'd be like you
know what let somebody else [ __ ] say
yeah like your hands saw you're gonna
put holes in your precious hands yeah
you know how long we like I you know I
paid good money to keep those hands
together all throughout your life like
so
Jason uh is an exceptional
father I wish and I've said this often
that I Jason him was a dad before me I
got a grown ass kid my daughter Harley
23.
um Jason's daughter Logan is seven if
there is any justice in the world Jason
would have been a dad before me so that
I could have seen how to properly parent
how to how to be a great dad I thought I
was a pretty good dad you know I was
like I'm going to be more communicative
than my father was you know she's I'm
gonna have a relationship with my kids
she's always gonna know what's on my
mind and [ __ ] I mean everybody does they
just have to listen to a [ __ ] podcast
but like I I that was my thing I was
like I'm gonna have a better
relationship with my kid than my dad had
with me and that wasn't like complaining
I just wish that I knew my father better
before he left this world
um I thought I was doing good by
improving that and then I watched Jason
raise Logan for the last seven years and
it's
um it's a a clinic a humbling clinic in
what being a dad truly should be what
being a father truly should look like
um think about how entertaining Jason
Muse is on a regular basis now imagine
you have that built in at your house 24
7 365 and the show was directed at you
that's what his daughter gets all the
time so
when he said to me
I want to do a new podcast and I was
like oh okay interesting you know
because I'm a guy that don't want to
rock the boat and I was like we got a
brand we got a strong brand chainsaw and
Bob got open going on for 12 [ __ ]
years why are you gonna [ __ ] he said
I'm not [ __ ] with I just want to add
something to it I have other things to
talk about and I was like you I I we I
know everything you have to talk about
and he said I want to do a podcast
called Father's Day
and I was like huh uh okay why you want
to talk about being a dad and he's like
yes and right away I was Charmed by that
I was like oh you know what
I get it like all right I was a dad and
now I'm at you know I'm still a dad
one's a dad always a dad but my kid's
out of the house Harley 23 she owns her
own house and [ __ ] my child rearing uh
days are behind me and that sounds
[ __ ] horrible that term but uh you
know I'm done raising kids Jason's still
in the thick of it you know he got
[ __ ] decades more of this [ __ ] to go
so the premise is like uh Father's Day
with Jane Silent Bob is uh us I guess
talking about
being dads yeah
um tell them about you being a dad man
tell them about your relationship with
Logan
uh I will I'll just start with
um
sorry this is awesome it's gonna take me
a sec to to get in the swing of things
but I'm very excited about this because
like Kevin said we've done good old
forever
um but we we've done it live
um and it's been a while since we did it
consistently and I'm very excited about
hopefully we you know I don't know what
we've decided if we'll do it weekly or
what have you
um but this will be able to do more
consistently whereas Jay and Silent Bob
good old was a live show yeah so we did
it when venues with venues would have us
and you know at a time we were like
banking rocking the shows and stuff but
like at a certain point that show is so
confessional and so personal that it's
like you actually need some time to go
live a life to be able to come back and
talk about it on a show like we would go
on tour sometimes do like 15 dates in a
row and like by date seven Jason's like
I don't have anything left to talk about
yeah yeah yeah and then then we open
with material about like so we were just
in another town last night doing this
exact same thing and then we drove here
and that's all that's happened yeah and
luckily sometimes things would happen on
the road so that that made it a little
bit to talk about that and I feel like
this will be the same thing but I feel
like uh going back uh I'll start with
what I what I think is great uh for
anyone that doesn't know
um I don't think I've ever talked about
this but uh you know I'm 48 now Logan's
seven and a half or so about seven and a
half
um is you know I was almost 40 and I
remember uh my 40th birthday was coming
up probably three months before my 40th
birthday
um and I remember talking with my wife
my wife uh you know is 13 years younger
than I am and at the point I was you
know we had talked about it a couple
times but we weren't ready and then when
I was about to be 40 I was like man I
don't don't think uh I'm ever going to
have kids man it was something I've
always wanted
um you know even when this is true yeah
you were always talking about having
kids even when you were a kid you were
talking about like having kids you were
always interested in it and that
probably I'm no [ __ ] armchair analyst
but
you you had an unorthodox childhood to
say the least you could listen to Jay
and Son Bob get old and over the course
of hundreds of episodes and hear Jason's
uh life story and stuff first six
episodes like encapsulate his life story
but
Jason of course like all of us had a dad
but he didn't know his dad he didn't
know your dad not at all yeah still to
this day I haven't seen a picture of him
so so you grew up without the the the
central male role model like who who
raised you all women so I was raised uh
but mainly by my grandmother my aunt and
my mom but my mom would you know the
first couple years she was sober took
care of me and then she would get strung
out on she was a drug addict
um and then my grandma would take care
of me for a year you know a year two
years my mom would get better I'd go
back live with her for a year then she
had strung out and I go back with my
grandmother uh another time I went and
lived with this random family because my
grandma was too ill to take care of me
and then eventually I went back with my
mom and then my mom went to jail and
then I went and moved in with my aunt my
Aunt Alice so mainly I was around women
all women it was my grandma my aunt aunt
and my mother and none of them my
grandma's uh husband had passed before I
was born or while I was my mom my dad I
never met and my aunt had a husband but
he didn't live with it was very weird
situation it was a weird dynamic yes
that's Bud white yes Bud yeah and he had
his own apartment
um but he'd come over constantly and
they'd hang out and stuff but you know
he wasn't around like uh you know to
like show you how to be like to be a
male role model be a dude in the house
how weird to be like he may have cracked
the code right like where he's just like
look we're married but I don't have to
live with her and now yeah I said we're
gonna live someplace else and that way I
can come over and date her still it's so
interesting yeah he's a weird dynamic
when they would sit at the kitchen table
there's the the kitchen table uh was you
know in the kitchen but it was there's
the two windows facing the street and no
lie my aunt would sit there from when
she woke up to when she would go to bed
I mean she'd have to run Aaron's do
normal stuff but for the most part
that's where she'd hang out and he would
come over and sit at the table with her
sometimes they'd go in the living room
and she'd sit in her chair she had and
he would sit on the couch how old do you
think they are at this point uh this is
I mean they were playing uh my grandma
was 87 I saw when she passed and after
that I lived with her so I mean my aunt
had to be in her 60s and then to her 70s
and same with him but so what do you
think
the story let's extrapolate do you think
the story was because this is the writer
in me it's just like okay
he cheated on her
she found out and she was like you get
the [ __ ] out bud white but she wouldn't
divorce him and so he spent the next 30
Years like this way with her where she
was like you could come into the kitchen
you can come into the living room but
she's like you're never gonna touch this
[ __ ] it's never again but white yeah
you know I they I don't
I don't uh I don't know if it was that
as much as you know I realize now as
we're talking about it you know my aunt
never had a bet she didn't sleep in a
bedroom so I almost felt like it was it
was out of convenience for whether their
living situation I don't know why she
didn't want to leave maybe because my
grandma was downstairs I mean until she
passed maybe that's the thing maybe she
was staying there for your grandma yes
and Bud White's like I won't [ __ ]
stay in this house because my brother
lived in the other there's two rooms
bedrooms in the house upstairs it was a
duplex downstairs one bedroom my grandma
lived in upstairs was two bedrooms my
brother lived in one and before I moved
in it there was a second bedroom but it
was it was storage All Storage she for
some reason she didn't want to live in
there stay in there so and it was it was
pretty tiny actually
um she mainly slept on the couch she
slept in it sat in a chair and I would
sleep on the couch I think we're piecing
it together I think she was there for
your grandma yes and didn't want to
leave
there's only so far I'm willing to go in
this marriage living with your
mother-in-law I'd rather stay at my own
apartment yeah because I believe did she
ever go over to his place yeah I don't
not not I know she'd go over maybe to
like see him and do stuff but not hang
out there that was probably they hung
out it was the booty call she would
never do it probably she would never do
it at the house she was like I always
got to be seen at the kitchen table but
when she went over to Bud White's
[ __ ] sex Palace bachelor pad I'm sure
he lived he lived above Bart Bart the
barber Bart the barber kids uh in our
hometown of Highlands was a figure of
Fascination uh to not just the folks of
the Town particularly the kids Bart had
been in the service I believe if I
remember correctly and uh maybe had you
know stepped on a grenade whatever he
had lost one of his legs yeah but he was
a barber so it fascinated people because
they're like that's support the
one-legged Barber yeah yeah because I
guess the rationale you know they're
saying do you know the little quote that
for him what was it Barb blew a fart and
blew his leg apart is that the secret
origin that's what happened I'm like I
think he had he got his like mortared
off he's like no no no
fart it's so crazy I remember that but
as kids you'd run around and be like yo
there's Bart Bart blew a fork and blew
his leg apart you know and Bart's just
like you use the term blue twice in that
be better writers
um so he lived above Bart yeah he did he
lived in the apartment so Parts uh
Barbershop was downstairs and I I saw
something I just remember that and then
years later he moved into Patek Towers
or whatever the nursing homes elderly
folks live in Highlands and he lived
there for years
um how wild man that [ __ ] like that
was how you were raised yeah and yet you
turned out to be an amazing dad the
correlation must be that like
you know you were like I'm gonna be what
I never had for the kid was that ever a
conscious thing or just an unconscious
thing like did you ever have a moment
where you're like I'm since I didn't
have a dad or a father figure I'm gonna
be like an amazing father figure in a
movie in the movie of your life that's a
scene yeah where you have a conversation
with yourself or with the kid did you
ever have that moment flashback to yours
that yeah well definitely I might I
remember that a big thing for me was I
knew I never wanted to have a kid before
I was settled like I didn't want to have
a kid with someone I wasn't married to
or have a kid uh if I wasn't financially
okay even you know I don't think they
want to replicate the situation your mom
yeah that was a big strong thing and
that's why again I feel like uh you know
I didn't plan on I I mean that that's
why I was almost 40 when we had finally
got pregnant with Logan which is insane
considering like the amount of uh you
know with all due respect the amount of
fun and sex that you've had prior to
even meeting Jordan that there aren't at
least 20
children of yours somewhere out there
but you're right he he waited a long ass
time and found a woman an exceptional
woman who runs our company
um but he didn't find her that way it
wasn't like she was running our company
it was like hello
um uh Jordan because she has such poor
taste in men fell in love with Jason and
benefited us both yeah because she was
like a UCLA kid like business major and
[ __ ] and
she's married to Jay at a certain point
and you know she was like well my fate
is tied to his [ __ ] fate if you don't
eat I don't eat I'm gonna make sure he
[ __ ] eats and whipped his [ __ ] into
shape you know if I can brought in her
mom goose who like cleaned up Jason's
Financial record and whatnot uh game
credit oh yeah good credit for the first
time in his life all the adult [ __ ] that
he
passed by when he was in you know
[ __ ] in the throes of drugs when he
was younger and stuff
so she did whip him in shape and turn
them into like a grown ass man as much
of a grown-up as he could be because
he's still got like a kid's heart why
not which is part of what makes him such
a great dad but when they had their kid
which was like April 1st uh well seven
years ago so what is it
2015. yeah 2015.
um it was like a major life shift uh in
our world because well a suddenly Jay
was responsible for a human being
um and everyone was like what's that
going to be like you know because Jay
historically has had times where he's
not the most responsible person in the
world and when you think of Jason Mew as
the first thought that comes to your
head is not like great dad
so the whole our whole world like stood
by going like what's this going to be
like and everyone was blown away you
know
how Jason Rose to the occasion I'll
never forget we were shooting Jay and
Silent Bob reboot
and we hadn't seen Ben uh Affleck for a
long time he'd kind of fallen out of our
lives and vice versa and that movie was
a reunion of sorts and he came out to
New Orleans where we were shooting to do
the big Holden Chasing Amy sequel scene
in the movies exceptional in that scene
he's fantastic
um
when he was on set he would not stop
talking about Jason he was just like
[ __ ] Muse man like
see like he's [ __ ] like married and
like his wife is like a normal person
and he [ __ ] he's got a kid and the
kid's like great and he's like like last
time Ben had paid attention Jason maybe
wasn't in the the best place or whatever
and and Ben had always been very you
know supportive and and super friendly
with Jason he put him in rehab a few
times back in the day Jason went to work
with Ben on his first movie Gone Baby
Gone you were with him the whole time
yeah yeah in Boston yeah he's Jason
lived in in this house which is my house
which I bought from Ben years ago but
even though I've lived in it for 20
years and he only lived in it for less
than a year we still call it Ben's house
uh Jason slept in Ben's house long
before I ever did before I slept in my
own house
uh it you know he's had a tight bomb
with the guy over the years and stuff so
but the you know Ben was gone for like
the almost the better part of like 10
years and then when he checked back in
you know on the reboot shoot he met an
entirely different Jason Muse that he
was gushing
about the whole time and particularly
the parent thing being a dad like did
you see how [ __ ] good he is with that
kid he's so if he was Ben was interested
in like us as parents and I think that's
because he too
is apparent and that's like the part of
our lives that we didn't share when we
all like kind of went our separate ways
I think I'd already had Harley
but yeah Harley was on Jersey girl and
stuff like that but like he was
fascinated by Harley too he's like oh my
God man she's like [ __ ] smart and
she's a really great actress
yeah she turned out well like he would
sit there and have conversations with
her and be like she's [ __ ] smart and
then he was just fascinated and and
delighted by
like where Jason
is in Life or was when we were shooting
it but back in 2019 but is still today
so I honestly feel like that's probably
why we got invited to the wedding
um Ben and Jen got Ben and Jennifer
Lopez got married recently and you know
uh one day
through a very you know complicated like
standby for email yeah we got these
invites to to the wedding and that we
didn't know there was going to be one
they got married in Vegas and and so I
was like right on there that's it
they're done but uh Jennifer wanted to
have like a day where they celebrated
with friends and family and stuff
so that they put together this second
wedding and um we got invited and
you know the the real it was it was like
oh my God it was great our boy he's
getting married and blah blah and and
then you look at the invite and it's
like you know
formal
of white formal attire yeah yeah
and I'm like why formal attire what do
you mean and it means that everybody is
going to be wearing white has to wear
white in order to attend like it's
mandatory and so I was like oh man I'm a
I I'm gonna look like the [ __ ] Stay
Puft Marshmallow Man
at best Colonel Sanders
you know or at worst
um and then
ultimately I think I looked more like a
Backstreet Boys member it was great yeah
you look good it was uh it was uh you
know I I was fretting the outfit uh him
he wasn't because he [ __ ] get dressed
in anything and stuff and Jordan knows
how to dress Jason
um but me I was like I'm [ __ ] this
I'm just completely [ __ ] Jennifer
fixed me though she saw saved my day
because my wife Jennifer not Ben's wife
Jennifer
um because she was like just have you
know she I was getting a stylist because
I was like I I don't know how to [ __ ]
buy a white anything
and uh Jennifer's like just tell the
stylist to cut your pants into George
and I was like oh that would be yeah
that'd make me more comfortable
and God damn it if that wasn't like the
the [ __ ] thing that most people
picked up on like the picture I posted
an Instagram picture and picture on
Twitter and it wound up going to a bunch
of Articles and stuff and um that's what
everyone talked about was like he wore a
customized version of his familiar
George and [ __ ] I was like thank you
thank you and the best looked good too
it's good I think I think the outfits
look good I think it turned out good but
I felt the same way I was like I don't
know well every part of me is just like
wait I gotta go to a place like this
ain't happening in Los Angeles we gotta
fly to Georgia and then we gotta take a
second flight to Savannah and then I
Gotta Wear special clothes like this
feels like Catholic School like I
haven't lived my life this way in
decades I've gone out of my way to build
a life where I could wear [ __ ] Jorts
and and you know dress like a [ __ ] 12
year old forever and not do anything I
don't want to do or not go wherever I
don't want to go but you know is our boy
and we love him and so you know
I've got skin in that relationship game
because I was there when they got
started and stuff so I was like you know
um
like Jennifer was just like look bro
it's about Kevin Smith like 24 7 365.
let it be about somebody else
it is hard it's hard to I realize it's
that's what I feel like my last two
weeks have been like to me it's I've
realized how hard it is to do things
nonstop and again I I get sometimes it's
I feel like I can adjust my cognitive
reframe my mind and stuff but it
literally after like two weeks the last
two weeks has been like you have to do
this you have to go here you have to go
to this uh Premiere you have to do this
and again we'll swing it back full
circle to the kid and I realize it's
like that all the time it's so different
with the kid I feel like as much as I
have to do things for the kid or or
um and things I don't want to do it's it
doesn't feel the same way like having to
get on a bus I wanted to go to the
wedding and I was excited and I'm so
happy I went but like the oh I gotta get
on a plane just like you said I had to
dress in white but and it like it really
messes my head
um and just like last night even I
wanted to go to Premiere I think it's
awesome I want to do the carpet and
bring the kid which was amazing adorable
beautiful shots of you three on the road
like I have to go at this time I have to
get you know I have to drink dressing
well because think about it it's this
simple you were a kid
then we made clerks and then because of
that you got to be a kid forever
and kids generally get to do what they
want you know they do what they're told
of course but like who's got more
freedom than a [ __ ] kid
um
when our freedoms are infringed upon
because we've built these lives for
nearly three decades of like utter
[ __ ] Freedom like I ain't doing
anything that I don't want to do I ain't
dressing it [ __ ] way I don't want to
dress like [ __ ] that that's the other
world and [ __ ]
to be presented with a set of options
where it's like you have no options yeah
like you have to do these things if you
want to be involved in this thing or
like in the case of like we're releasing
a movie so it's like there's a Premiere
there's a junket yeah you're doing this
uh we fly to Toronto this weekend to do
a show the next weekend the tour begins
so we're in a very busy Corridor and
it's not
they're not all things Jason would elect
to do by choice
given his druthers he wouldn't do half
of these things so it amplifies a
situation by being forced into having to
do it too yes and then you're you know
people are like yeah but don't you want
to do it isn't it fun and you're like
yes of course having a Premiere can be
fun I guess but not the way that like
Jason's being asked to engage with it if
it was just like hey show up when you
want do whatever [ __ ] you want it'd be
great but it's like you need to be there
at this time you need to be standing
with these people we're going to have
you with your family and then push your
family out and put you with these people
and then pictures of these people and
then you have to talk to these people
and you have to do this before you can
even just sit down and [ __ ] watch the
movie so yeah it's it all that shit's an
anathema to [ __ ] Muse and that's
what makes him
like a kid because when you're like you
know hey we can't do a thing
he's like why not
you know suddenly I don't get it why
because he's used to shaping the world
to be exactly what he wants it to be but
sometimes like it can be worth it you
know the whole time we were going out to
the wedding it's like
oh man [ __ ] how many flights how many
hours to get there yeah where do we have
the right hotel room where are we yeah
oh my God it's hot in this [ __ ] town
I Gotta Wear it I'm gonna sweat through
these clothes
all of it
vanished the minute I saw him standing
there smiling it's like a [ __ ] movie
man he came up out of like nowhere and
uh you know it turns out later on it was
like from The Boathouse or something
yeah yeah and then just sauntered up
we're all sitting there like I don't
know 150 of us or something like that
very intimate like I read a lot of
reports about all these famous people
are going to be there and it really
wasn't it was like Matt was his Matt and
Ben and Jen were as like as famous as it
gets it was more family and friends and
stuff
so he saucered up looked like like a
[ __ ] movie star from the you know
from the 40s like a super tall Carrie
Grant who was already tall uh or a
Humphrey Bogart like he had the the
white jacket with the black pants tucks
I think Ben's got full beard and he
looks like a grown ass man he's still
got boyish face and sparkling his eye
and stuff
and you know I've said a few times we've
seen Ben over the course of met him when
we were auditioning for Mall Rats in my
second movie and stuff so 27 years I've
I've known Affleck and you've known
Affleck and you know we've watched them
go from like [ __ ] hey it's Ben to
like Jesus Christ that's [ __ ] Ben
Affleck worldwide movie star and [ __ ]
and over the course of those years you
know you have Joys and you have uh
sorrows and whatnot and and um
thankfully the rarefied air that we get
to breathe in this industry there have
been a lot more highs you know and so
I've seen Ben be happy is my point
um you can see it yourself when he won
an Oscar [ __ ] it's look up happiness
in the definition and there's the
physical
representation of it where Ben and
matter holding their Oscars and
breathlessly trying to get through their
speech to thank you speech and stuff
pure joy
uh take all the happy moments I've ever
seen that dude have and all the times
he's he's ever laughed so hard that you
knew he was enveloped in joy in that
particular moment stuff because he's got
great sense of humor if you can get him
laughing you feel like a real
accomplishment and stuff take all the
joy I've ever seen on that
motherfucker's face or he ever
exemplified in this lifetime
done touch
the joy that was on his face when he
I'll never forget he stood up he stood
walked up stood in place
and just seemed like the Buddha
Serene Joy on his face like a man who's
lived a life who went through some [ __ ]
learned some [ __ ]
grew and suddenly was about to be you
know spoiled with the reward
that he worked so hard for like he grew
up to get to this moment and look at him
looking at Jennifer coming down the
aisle who was absolutely [ __ ]
breathtakingly beautiful
um
the whole wedding was [ __ ] gorgeous
she's got Exquisite taste but looking at
him look at her bro
made me ashamed
of like
like you know I gotta step up my gift
yeah and like I really like I was like
I gotta [ __ ] I gotta show that now
you know I probably did back when we got
married like 23 [ __ ] years ago but
like
it was inspiring like it would have it
would have made the most cold-hearted
cynic believe in [ __ ] true love where
you're like look at them they have a
fairy tale ending
to a three-act story and the ending of
that story we're standing here at the
end of it and the beginning of the brand
new story which is like them
getting to do what they wanted to do 20
years ago like start their lives
together and they have the kids too
which we'll get back yes Father's Day
yes Father's Day and but again it was he
talked a lot about the kids the kids
were a huge thing a big part of it and
stuff and and I think that's also for uh
it's like it's beautiful they worked
them into it into everything into the
bounds into the ceremony the kids were a
big part of the
of the it and
it was we had a conversation at the
wedding me and Muse where he was like
that's what like that's what I would do
like I would definitely have my kids
involved in [ __ ] like that I remember
Jordan's like you're not getting
divorced he was like no I don't know I
would never but if I was in that
situation
um
but that's when he was like we were at
Ben's wedding
um the reception afterwards and stuff
when Jay was like I want to do a podcast
and I'm like right now
I don't think Ben would appreciate that
I think all the attention should be on
the bride but I'm game you know every
Saga has a Middle Ages what happens to
Jade Bob good old and everyone at the
wedding's looking at us like what the
[ __ ] going on with your jersey friends
uh he was like no when we get home I
said what's the podcast going to be
about
and he's like about being a dad I'm
gonna call Father's Day and I my
addition was like can we add with Jane
Silent Bob and he was like I guess so
that's what I brought to the table
um but he promised me that like you know
early on if you listen to Jay and Silent
Bob get old like I was the host of the
first six episodes and telling Jay's
story and he was kind of co-signing it
and then on episode seven which was like
when we the first episode we ever did
where we ran out of content yeah
um you know there was no storyline it
was like we have to figure out what the
show is now
it was in front of a live audience and I
remember like passing the ball to Jason
and he just dropped the ball where I was
like what do you think and he goes I
don't know yeah it was and I'm like in
front of all these people I'm like you
better [ __ ] know something so after
the show I I told him I was like look
I'm never doing that again with you if
you [ __ ] if I throw you the ball and you
just stare at me dumbfounded like a
[ __ ] dog looking at a ferris wheel or
something like that you need to you need
to always have material yeah in your
back pocket so Jason started keeping
things written down in a notebook so
that no matter where we were doing a
show he would have it on stage and he
could always bring it up it infected his
real life because he would just carry it
around being [ __ ] social Gatherings
and [ __ ] like when there was a long
conversation Leaf through and be like
did you know that the other day I had an
interesting uh interaction on an
airplane and people were like
do tell Jason so
back then there was always a fear of
like you know oh is he gonna have any
content like before we do every live
show for years I would always be like do
you have something to say yeah do you
have do you have a sex story do you have
a drug story do you have an opening
material do you have some banter some
Chit Chat and always like making sure
that his [ __ ] guns are loaded before
we go out on stage
him at Ben's wedding
was completely different this this
wasn't a guy who was had to be goaded
into something this was a dude who was
like you know I've known Jason forever
longer than I've known Ben obviously and
I can read him like a book and you know
Jason's adorable when he wants something
he's omnipresent when he wants something
and so suddenly it was like oh he wants
this I recognize this version of Jay
this is something that he wants like
most times I'm like Jordan's probably
pushing him into this but you seemed
very very passionate about the idea of
us doing a podcast
um I was gonna sneeze where you talk
about
fatherhood particularly well it's the
lifestyle which smells to me like a
lifestyle podcast this sounds it smells
very goopy to me like [ __ ] Gwyneth
Paltrow like next you're gonna be like
can we sell some candles made from my
vagina that would be awesome you know my
[ __ ] kid told me last night so we had
the premiere last night and um
afterwards I like went out to eat with
my kid and their friends and stuff at
swingers at like two in the morning and
my kid goes oh my God she goes Logan is
so [ __ ] hysterical man like at one
point Jason was pointing at the poster
and he's pointing to a picture of
himself on the poster and he's saying to
uh Logan he's going this guy looks like
he would have some poo on his head and
she was like
and then Jason pointed to a picture of
him of another man and he was like this
man has a vagina and the kid was like
and then [ __ ] Harley was like how
come you never joke like me like that
with me when I was a kid I was like what
told you that men had vaginas was that
all about she just loves the words right
what she loves I I don't know why I have
this thing where like it because you
know for a while there was the whole you
know which again is is an awesome the
process of seeing her as a baby and and
learning things and learning to talk and
all that but you know there was a period
where she's like you know boys have
penises and girls have vaginas and stuff
like that checks out the the end and you
know the school she goes to they really
said hey look you know you don't want to
call it uh you know your your wee-wee
your private part anything like that
because you don't you don't want her to
get confused if someone you know I
stigmatized that for later on yeah and
stranger anything or somebody's like do
you want to see my penis they're like I
don't know what that is yeah exactly so
it makes sense and so uh so one day I
was joking with her and I was like hey
we were I was washing her in the bathtub
and stuff I was like here take the
washcloth and I said clean your penis
and she said I don't have a penis and I
said I know I know I said all right well
I'm going to go to the bathroom and then
I'm going to wipe my vagina
you don't have a vagina and she really
loved it so now every once in a while
I'll joke with her about that and the
school's gonna pull you up for a
conference going like we went out of our
way to use proper terms so as not to
confuse the child and you're literally
telling her she has a penis and that you
have a vagina no I waited to I waited
till it was it was like melted um I
guess what would be
molded in her head that she knows a boy
is a penis yeah you didn't [ __ ]
shatter her like a grower in a Skinner
box you're like let's just see what
happens if we tell this kid the whole
time like her mom Mommy's told me I had
a vagina what's going on you know I said
no I waited till she really uh knew and
again and she does and she's more I'm
not the one that started the poop thing
but she first she loves the poop emoji
if she ever grabs my phone she'll be
like hey I want to text Mommy real quick
and she just texts a poo so again so I
think that it's just naughty it's just
like the edge yeah that's where you
could see the you and her because I
think like the older she gets the more
and more she looks exactly like blonde
Jordan yeah yeah but and and she's very
smart and she can speak [ __ ] French
and all of that speaks to Jordan more so
than Jason not saying Jason's not smart
but like he barely knows the English
language let alone another language
um but where I see you
is the [ __ ] like you know
like you're the fun you know it's it's
funny it seems like the kid's always
going to be caught in a crossfire
between doing the right thing like her
mother does and I don't mean like being
a good person but like you know Jordan's
[ __ ] real smart and and just capable
as [ __ ] like we are where we are our
business would be dead we wouldn't have
a James on Bob reboot or Clerk's [ __ ]
three left to our own devices me and
Jason
um Jordan is like truly the brains
beyond the operation so that is
definitely going to be on display that
clearly she's a smart kid
but she's also going to be crafty like
her old man oh yeah she's so that's the
combo the smart and [ __ ] crafty which
makes her practically Lex Luthor
she does she she won't lie
which is great she won't lie to her mom
so it's like she has this she's like
I'll lie to this ass yes because he lies
to me about having a vagina she'll try
to manipulate like she I could see her
like craftiness of manipulating like
with me and then like her mom will come
in and she's like okay I did eat the
candy bar you know but with me she's
like well I only had one piece and she
like we'll hide it and I'll be like are
you sure you only had one piece she's
like yeah and then like I'll see that
she meant like really she broke it in
half and had that one piece of the one
giant piece exactly but like with her
mom she's like all right Mom I only had
one quarter of a piece which is smaller
she's it's she's more morally rigid with
Jordan and with you she's like uh you
know Dad Cuts Corners I cook yes
it's very it's it's amazing and again
it's the whole thing I've realized is
you know from when we found out again I
was you know I was turning 40 and I was
like man I'm not gonna have a kid is a
real bummer and then you know Jordan
being like all right let's try I was
like can we try but so when I hit 40 you
know if if it doesn't happen by the time
I'm hitting 41 I get it but let's try
while I'm 40. so we tried and that we
got you know we really lucked out I
don't know if it's luck or whatever but
within like two months three months you
know we found out she was pregnant
um after trying after she got off birth
control and started you know take doing
this and doing that back in 2014 yeah
and uh and yeah and it was in within
like three months which was amazing
um and then it's like but again the
whole process which I'm sure most people
have gone well I don't know about
everyone but maybe I have a little bit
more panicky Jordan tells me all the
time a helicopter dad and and panic and
and worry about everything but every
every appointment at the doctors
beforehand worried like I hope you know
the sonogram everything goes right and
everything and then when I hope uh you
know when she was born I was hoping
doing everything uh hearing and eyes and
all that stuff of course and then every
little move
um but again it's like I've been getting
more at ease and trying to be at ease
because you know what I'm learning is if
I'm anxious the kid feels that and she
gets anxious
um but again it really you know you hear
people say it changed your life and it
really has for me in the sense like I
said like if I have to do something I
don't want to do and it's for something
first my if Jordan's like I need you to
go drive and pick this thing up and I
planned on streaming or whatever
um I was like man my brain was ready to
stream and now I have to go do this
thing but if she's like hey I need to go
pick up Logan's birth certificate for
something I'm like all right I gotta go
you know so it's it's very interesting
uh and that's just how I feel and and so
it's it's been awesome so much so that
you know I've been sort of egging on
like when you think maybe we should try
to have another one and we've been
discussing it there's no way on Earth
your lady would agree to have a second
child I I remember she was like
you had to talk her into the first one
um and she's an exceptional mother but
like she yeah she was kind of like uh I
mean she was young yeah [ __ ] you how
old were you so I I was turning 40 and
she's 13 years younger so she was like
27 she was like bro these are my [ __ ]
fun years yeah I really think I won't be
sorry I had asked her like a couple
years before that one because she was
like 25 and she's like well look I'm 25
and and all that and and we were
traveling a bunch with the podcasts and
all that stuff she's like I'm just not
ready so and then again two years later
three years later I was about to hit 40.
it's a miracle that she gave you one kid
so I think you should count your
blessings and [ __ ] there's no
annoying Jordan as I know Jordan and
again I [ __ ] talk to Jordan like
literally every day multiple times
there's and and allowing for the fact
that of course yes you know her a little
better than me being that you're married
I there's no way that she would agree to
having a second kid I don't know yeah
why she'd been talking about well I'll
tell you what you know why because you
know we've discussed it and it believe
it or not we found out something
interesting as a woman when you turned
35 when you hit the h35 or older you're
considered geriatric for for giving
birth because you know I guess that's
right because that's late late isn't it
which is very important how weird to be
like 35 and somebody's like you're old
exactly senior citizen [ __ ] get on that
bus the SCAT bus yeah so so that being
said like you know we found that out
when she was doing one of our checkups
regular doctor's appointment uh got a
college Department
um but so you know I she's like all
right like if we're gonna try we we
probably should try now so we've been
you know trying to work on a little bit
a little this and that we have sex once
uh every three months and no I'm just
kidding
no but we we have we've been trying uh
we've been trying and she's she wants to
try
um and we're gonna give it a shot uh
right now for you know at this age 35 if
it doesn't happen we're gonna you know
we'll see I don't know how what the
deadline is how many how many months
we'll let it try to happen wait so the
point of this podcast is you want to
talk about
trying to have another baby
nope the point of this podcast is that
we are having another baby what yes sir
are you [ __ ] kidding nope nope sorry
okay I was gonna try to let it build up
and on but yes uh so Jordan and I've
been trying for about three four months
and we found out she's pregnant what
oh yes sir yes sir so you know this is
why are you [ __ ] serious we're having
number two brother yeah are you are we
really doing a podcast or is this like
were you is this a weird way of telling
me that you're having another kid it is
I'm sorry I started getting I actually
started getting emotional because I
realized I am Telling You for the first
time where she's pregnant that is
unbelievable holy [ __ ] look at this
yes sir my man is fertile and more
infertile [ __ ]
way to flip the script like there's no
the woman I know there's no way she was
gonna
[ __ ] consider it and now you're
having two unless we again Logan
honestly has been so it's so it's been
so awesome with Logan
um and holy [ __ ] [ __ ] bro we got
number two man number two so everyone
um Jordan's pregnant and we're having
our second and uh when did you find out
we found out uh it was about three weeks
ago or so about three or four it was
about three weeks a month again time has
has been compressed because we've been
traveling and such and meanwhile
Jordan's been building the tour and
[ __ ] finishing the movie and stuff
like that yes sir so
um holy [ __ ] I love it bro so that's
what I want to talk about that's what
we're gonna continue to talk about
because eventually we're gonna get to
find out the sex of the baby
um and hopefully we could talk about
that on here bro look I'm gonna stop I'm
gonna put pin in it right there and be
like I'm very I'm I'm beyond thrilled
for you this is [ __ ] ecstatic uh as a
person as a friend like oh my God you're
gonna have another kid this is amazing I
gotta tell you as a [ __ ] podcaster
I'm very impressed by this I think you
just gave us like structure thank you
like we now we know we get at least nine
months out of this [ __ ] podcast right
and then you gotta raise that kid
so that too and you're still raising
another kid so we got like content
Galore it ain't like [ __ ] you know uh
you you'll never be like I ran out of
sex stories because now you've got
like a waterfall of content kids stories
seven years worth of Logan plus whatever
Logan keeps doing yeah and I would
suggest that we bring Logan on to the
show definitely awesome just to have her
talk about poo or vaginas or [ __ ]
penises definitely for anybody who
listens for the first time and they
haven't seen or know Logan it'll be fun
to to hear her and she'll probably have
a blast she again she's starting to she
still gets shy of certain things but
she's starting to love the idea some
there's been a couple times where
someone will will take a picture of me
while her and I will walk in she's like
Daddy why do they want a picture of you
I was like well you know I try to
explain a little bit but then we were at
one of the like school events and one of
the like other parents like a friend
that there wanted a picture and then the
kid that she knows from school that that
was her age she's in school it was like
wait why does my daddy's friend want a
picture and Logan's like well because my
daddy does movies
so you get it a little bit she was she
seemed very comfortable at the premiere
not like terrified and hiding behind you
guys she was like she's a girly girl too
she you could tell she's like I like
dressing up and makeup and [ __ ] so I
think she was like kind of into it but
yeah I I look she's your kid so she's
gonna be forward-facing like yeah no
there's going to be a time where she
likes to be the center of attention
um and it's a lethal mix with her
because she's a pretty kid so she's
probably gonna be a pretty [ __ ]
teenager but she's a pretty person who
wants to be the center of attention yeah
girl you yeah oh no
well Sam this is where I'm wondering
again like you the parenting of it all
for me is like so much between what
Jordan and I the difference and trying
to learn because it is like certain
things she'll like that's like for
example she wanted to watch the movie
last night the kid the kid Logan wanted
to go guys who did the clerk Premiere uh
and she did the carpet and then I
brought it I was like well she's in the
movie too she's in a scene in the movie
and so for me I was like you know what I
wanna I wanted to see the movie because
I think she'll enjoy seeing all of us
seeing herself right but I was like and
the curse words I don't care so much
yeah so I was unless somebody's like
vagina I know exactly what that is yeah
my dad's got one he's gotta clean it and
so she you know so I was like I don't
think it's something but Jordan's like
no I don't want and then other you know
we weren't sure if even the theater
would let her in as a kid that age so
again these are this is where I'm like
I'm still learning and trying to take uh
it's interesting the the just the whole
process well it's content bro like I'm
telling you like this is backdoor genius
which sounds exactly as sexy as I meant
it because a you've given us a concept
that has content Galore and doesn't stop
because like the stories about raising
kids never stop aside from all the Logan
stuff now you're gonna have all [ __ ]
baby number two
um and then
like uh then it also gives the us a
chance to follow your growth and and
chart your [ __ ] growth and shifting
attitudes as a parent man because if we
play like look we got
we've been doing Json Bob good old 12
years if we were doing Father's Day for
12 years from now Logan would be 19
which means we're gonna have all those
juicy [ __ ] teenage years where all
she wants to do is fight with you yeah
and date boys and you're like this
[ __ ] [ __ ] Brian man who likes
my daughter I want to [ __ ] kill him
I'm like he's 12 bro and we could go
back listen to this and it'll be like oh
listen to the cute little girl and how
much she loved her daddy and like her
being on here and she's like you know
what I'm back on the podcast you know 10
years later my father's a piece of [ __ ]
yeah I used to hate when people would
ask him for a [ __ ] picture
now when he's sleeping and [ __ ] out of
[ __ ] in his face no more poo it's poop
it's [ __ ] yeah
no more [ __ ] cute poo emojis look at
this I'm rubbing right in his [ __ ]
face
um she told I remember she is [ __ ]
crafty bro she told Harley
you know because uh something that we've
talked about on Jay and some Bob good
old and I'm sure it'll [ __ ] happen
we'll talk about it on Father's Day with
Jane Silent Bob is you know the kid is
part of the digital generation so she
lives with her face in a phone if they
would let her and Jordan is very strict
about like no no Jason not as strict and
so like sometimes she gets like way the
[ __ ] into
like watching oh yeah YouTube and stuff
like that but she'll sneak on I'll
she'll be like Daddy can I play bro I
let her play Roblox so I've downloaded
Roblox and there's this other Toca World
which is fine I've played with her and
it's nothing bad but I swear I'll walk
away to like use the restroom and then
make her a sandwich I'll come back and
I'll see her like messing with the phone
I'll be like what are you doing and she
won't be able to get out of it in time
and I'll look over and she's watching
YouTube now the good thing is she
usually watches YouTube she'll watch a
girl playing Roblox right like there's
this one person she loves Cookie Swirl C
which again is fine but the problem is
is the darn adds man the ads come in
between and the ads are always pointing
to something not always but sometimes
that I'm not it's not may I make a
suggestion yes if you buy YouTube yes
then you don't encounter ads ever ever
I'm subscribed to YouTube you know it's
a feat yeah yeah but I never see a
single ad ever so if you're watching
like CookieSwirlC okay if I'm watching
Cookie Swirl C then somebody should
investigate me as a 52 year old man
however if I was watching CookieSwirlC
it would be an uninterrupted watch
because I subscribed to YouTube all you
have to do is that look at me I'm
[ __ ] this is a parenting house
exactly the Elder parent passing it on
and that has nothing to do with
parenting I just knew that the uh Logan
told you know so Logan she likes to get
on the phone or on tablets and [ __ ]
play and she told the [ __ ] Jennifer
uh uh Harley once at the house she was
like um uh mommy and daddy don't want me
to be on YouTube a lot but sometimes
when daddy's sleeping I take his phone
and I put it in his face and it opens it
up yeah and I was like you could do that
that changed my life bro because I was
like I am now not leaving my phone
anywhere when I'm [ __ ] sleep I'm
putting it under a mattress because
somebody could just pick it up [ __ ]
open my [ __ ] up right with my face there
it's it's crazy that's that crafty Jason
Muse thinking no right there man she's
gonna be one to watch the whole time now
there's two to watch oh yes and you
don't even know what the second one's
gonna be not yet man but but again
knowing you beauty of this if you're if
if the universe wants to curse you two
girls because Jason and you know I don't
mean that because girls are terrible I
love having a daughter and chip but
Jason when he had a daughter like when
Logan was born he was like oh no I'm
gonna do it and I was like do what and
it was like bro one day some dude's
gonna try to date her I'm just gonna
wanna [ __ ] kill him I might kill a
[ __ ] I'm like hey you got like I
don't know 13 years to worry about that
b Maybe mind will change over time he's
like no and I was like why do you worry
so much about this and he's just like
because
because I've had so much sex
oh you're suddenly worried about the
[ __ ] uh the universe coming back to
bite you I don't think so I've seen thus
far you know you're laying the
groundwork by being an exceptional Dad
I'll tell you this much I feel bad for
any boy or girl whoever she winds up
[ __ ] dating because they gotta they
gotta hold a candle to you one of the
most entertaining people on the [ __ ]
planet uh the most like engaged with the
kid like you Jason dores his daughter so
like No Fly by Night like [ __ ] you
know hey what's up good looking dude is
gonna do it they're she's gonna that
[ __ ] is gonna have to put on a
show 24 7. to like because that's what
she's been being been accustomed to and
will continue to be accustomed to
wow dude [ __ ] this is brilliant I
love it I think we end here so we can
give surprises I know so what's the next
surprise I think well I don't know I
don't tell now right but next time we go
I don't know
we might know by then we might know by
then so please tune in next
week and find out it's a good hook look
at you you've learned after 12 years
thank you yeah I'm just a proud look I
know it's called Father's Day I'm as
proud as a [ __ ] dad thank you looking
at you coming up with something that
will sustain us like [ __ ] uh you know
we'll do this here in in the house and
[ __ ] and then after the reboot roach of
Jesus after the convenience tour which
by the way clerks three ladies and
gentlemen uh the convenience tour starts
on September 4th travels all across this
great land of ours tickets at
clerks3.movie or you could see it at the
fathom event screenings September 13th
through September 18th at a theater near
you uh tickets at fathom events.com or
at ceasemon.com
um but when the tour is done when the
convenience store is done and I'm done I
think by Christmas December or something
like that
we can go from being a home show to
doing it live yeah no taking it out into
the world and doing it in front of
people like get old yeah no I'm very
excited honestly because I feel like I
feel like this is a chance again because
again with with work with us traveling
um and just normal of course life stuff
we we do only see each other like once a
week so I feel like this will be uh us
seeing each other catching up and uh
getting to talk about the kid because
again I always there's all this stuff
with the kid that I want to talk about
but I don't necessarily you know I know
so many things you know what it'll do
too but maybe we don't do it as a live
show ever because that will like we get
old was always live so we're always
engineered to be
funny yeah without being conversation as
conversational as we could be but it was
always periodically every 30 seconds 45
seconds you're like we better say
something over people laugh otherwise
why are they 100 in a home show you have
the beauty of being for far more
meditative because you're not surrounded
by a bunch of people who you're feeling
the pressure that they're not laughing
their systems so it could be if we keep
it as a home show
that we will get into and find out more
about you and your parenting style than
we ever have on get old because of the
pressure of like you know that's nice
but we gotta [ __ ] do something funny
right here here instead we could just
try to be interested this is very
bro in a million year you continue to
surprise me because I never imagined one
day you'd be like I have a lifestyle
podcast we could do and bro we can get
rich off a lifestyle like we didn't get
rich off jameson.com yeah no [ __ ] man
[ __ ] we can make that goop money we
can make that [ __ ] who's the dude
who's uh the vegan dude who DK put me on
his podcast
um [ __ ] I've been on twice he's a great
guy he makes a [ __ ] bank bunch of
Bank yeah because it's called lifestyle
it's like when we were talking about Jay
and Son Bob good old that ain't a
lifestyle no it makes sense yeah yeah
this is talking about being a parent so
you can be like sponsored by Pampers yes
you might be putting us on that [ __ ]
fat corporate seat bro
sponsored by baby food yeah exactly baby
food in general it's the idea of the
concept of baby food this uh could be
the beginning of something beautiful I
think you [ __ ] stumbled onto it maybe
this is why we've worked together for as
long as we have waiting for your sheer
moment of Brilliance I've carried us
this far yes perhaps my father's day yes
we'll be the [ __ ] the the strong back
on which we brought into our geriatric
years I love it which apparently is 35
if you're a woman trying to have a baby
no Jesus who knew find out all sorts of
interesting [ __ ] just like that kids
every week right here on Father's Day
with Jane Salem Bob for Father's Day I'm
Kevin Smith Jason Muse uh Happy Father's
Day everybody
foreign
[Music]
greetings everybody and welcome to the
AKA ask Kevin every Saga has a 10-year
anniversary ladies and gentlemen and
this is what happens with Jay and Silent
Bob get old off Kevin Smith
[Music]